-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
And this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
Whatever.
I don't know, let me just do it.
I'm gonna just say it.
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to the news.
President Biden met
face-to-face today
with Russian President
Vladimir Putin
for the first time in a decade
Well, I say "face-to-face.
Biden keeps saying
"mono a mono."
That's right, President Bide
and Russian President
Vladimir Putin
met in Geneva today for abou
four hours with a few breaks
but no meals because
nobody would volunteer
to be the food taster.
After reporting that 70%
of eligible New Yorkers
have received at least one dos
of the coronavirus vaccine
Governor Andrew Cuomo yesterda
said,
"We can now return to life
as we know it."
And then to prove it, he was
immediately served a subpoena.
The White House is
reportedly planning
to invite more than 1,000 guests
to a 4th of July celebration
on the South Lawn,
which will feature fireworks
and a cookout.
And if you think you're gettin
anywhere near that grill,
think again.
That's right,
the White House is plannin
a 4th of July celebration
with more than 1,000 guests.
Oh, great idea.
I'm sure fireworks will
calm Major right down.
1,000 guests might be coming
but 1,000 guests
ain't be leaving.
Major's got to eat.
It was announced yesterday tha
Jared Kushner has signed a dea
to write a book that will focu
on his accomplishments
in the Trump administration.
And if you think he's thin..
Disneyland announced yesterday
that it will stop
temperature checks,
social distancing,
and mask mandates
for visitor while outdoors
but guests are not require
to provide proof of vaccination.
And this is cool.
They're finally reopening
Goofy's Wet Market.
[ Laughter ]
California and New York
yesterday
both lifted virtually all of
their coronavirus restrictions
So now residents can resum
moving back and forth
between the two,
never finding real happiness
and debating which one sucks
more until the day we all die.
And that's a classic Ally joke
Authorities in New York arrested
a man yesterday in Times Squar
after he was allegedly
caught masturbating
in the middle of a crowd.
Said New Yorkers, "Can you wal
while you do that?"
[ Laughter ]
That's right, authorities
arrested a man yesterday
in Times Square who was
allegedly caught masturbatin
in the middle of a crowd.
And now New York is back.
Major League Baseball yesterda
unveiled its plan
to ramp up enforcement
of the ban
on the use of sticky substance
by pitchers.
I don't know, as someone who's
spent a summer in New York
sticky balls
are just a fact of life.
[ Laughter ]
[Bleep] Scollins.
And finally,
Ford recently began producin
the 2021 Bronco SUV in Michigan,
25 years after it
stopped production
on the original model.
And just like the original
it has A/C.
[ Laughter ]
And people are like, "What's i
like to do a talk show --
what would it have been like
to do a talk show in the '90s?
Now I know.
That was a monologue, everybody.